foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
visualizing cancer biology through cell
culture inserts
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates and brought to
you by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Reyes amen Reyes is working as an r d
scientist having six plus years of
experience in cell and protein biology
he is focused on developing protocols
and workflows for various cell biology
applications
for a complete biography of today's
speaker click their name in the
presenter window at the top right of
your screen
Reyes welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thanks for joining today
my name is Reyes Ahmed I'm an r d
scientist at Thermo Fisher Scientific
in today's webinar I'll be talking about
the applications of cell culture inserts
specifically focusing on in the area of
cancer biology
so I'm going to discuss more in detail
about how we can effectively use the
cell culture insert system to model
multiple cell types thereby we can study
different events of cancer
so before we dive into the cell culture
inserts let's recap some basics of
cancer cells that defines the
characteristics compared to normal cells
every Cancer cell starts within mutation
in the genetic code of the cell which
corrupts the entire cell so upon
proliferation these cells uh correct
these corrupted cells divide and
increase in number that enlarges the
tissues around this local state is
called hyperplasia
followed by it leads to the abnormal
growth of tissues and organs around and
at this point it is called dysplasia
so later the cells are benign to their
local environment that's why we call
them tumor
but the real problem starts when these
corrupted cells uh tries to escape their
original environment thereby invading
other parts to the body
when it becomes malignant it adds more
complexity for our understanding of this
cancer cells
due to the properties such as migration
of cells from one place to another
Invasion through different physical
barriers and then they tend to induce
angiogenesis
such as forming their own blood vessels
to get continuous supply of nutrients
so why cancer cells are so complex
um so well over the years of research
many scientists have been figured out
different principles of cancer cells
trying to understand various events of
cancer among all the Hallmarks of cancer
described by Hanahan and Weinberg were
really helpful and acted as a blueprint
for
researchers to dissipate the cancer
cells mechanism
more importantly these Hallmarks helped
us to
model these in vitro as well as so that
we can understand them experiment them
and intervene different therapies to
stop these Hallmarks at an early stage
of cancer
so out of this Hallmarks uh the most
challenging Hallmarks which are
highlighted here that are difficult to
model in vitro are studying cancer cell
migration
Invasion and then tumor-induced
angiogenesis
so how do we study these cancer
phenomena in the lab conventionally we
have a well-established culture systems
such as monolayer where we can grow
single type of cells just to grow them
and then do simple assays such as
proliferation assays and truck
treatments
but we cannot study events like cell to
cell interactions and it's basically
lacking the actual tumor micro
environment so thereby it's uh it's it's
very difficult to study two different
cell types in a monolayer culture
and then we have co-culture models where
we can culture two type of cells
together which helps somewhat to
understand their interactive
interactions but at times these cells
are difficult to separate if you want uh
to analyze them individually
also it may require two different media
if you are considering two different
cells so which is a limitation for this
model
and then we have third uh 3D 3D culture
models which are very emerging such as
spirits and organite-based cultures
which mimics our enviro-like environment
it again we do have limitations as it is
still emerging and they are difficult to
reproduce and interpret their results
also these may not be very feasible to
study Hallmarks like uh cell migration
and Innovation so we need an alternative
culture system which is uh very well
established
so how do we solve this
so the idea here is instead of just
co-culturing two type of cells in a
monolayer so we can make use of
co-culture with interfaces which allows
us to grow two different type of cells
in a single vessel with a physical
barrier in between them
so these are named as interface cultures
so what you see on the right hand side
are regular cell culture well with an
insert at the center
so these inserts are called as cell
culture insects which basically divides
the cultural into two different
compartments an apical side and then
basal site with a porous membrane in
between
so this porous membrane helps in
movement of cells nutrients and growth
factors between the two compartments
just like our capillary system
so this is an excellent tool to mimic
tumor environment especially to study uh
events like cell to cell interactions
and migration of cells since each cell
type is physically separated from each
other in this system unlike the regular
culturing it's not cultured together as
monolayer
so typically these interface cultures
are classified into two types the first
one is liquid liquid interface culture
that is the most widely used in many
applications
and the second one is uh called L liquid
interface culture that are primarily
used in modeling the respiratory cells
of lung
is cell culture insert system helping to
study cancer phenomena
so if you see on the left hand side the
progression of tumor which involves
events such as migration and invasion in
response to various growth factors and
then it also leads to tumor-induced
angiogenesis and then paracrine
signaling between different cell types
so all these harmonics are easy to model
with the use of cell culture insects and
I will demonstrate how how do we model
these uh within examples in upcoming
slides
so in Real World Cell culture inserts
how do they look
well what you see here is uh called Nung
cell culture inserts in a carrier Plate
System developed by a Thermo Fisher
Scientific so it is a two compartment
multi-plate system consisting of
um
cell culture inserts with a porous
membrane a carrier plate and a regular
cell culture plate at the bottom
so the membrane inside the cell culture
inserts comes in three different pore
sizes to suit different experiments also
it is height adjustable so the carrier
plate height can be adjusted to increase
or decrease the distance between the
carrier plate and the bottom well so
this provides flexibility in in handling
the volume of media required in each
application
so this is the disabled wave of non-sell
culture inserts in a career pad system
so as you see in the picture it has the
regular multi-well plate as the lower
chamber uh carrier plate to hold insects
as a upper chamber and we have a
removable cell culture inserts which can
be placed at the center of the career
plate
so at first I would like to demo how to
perform migration of cancer cells in
response to different chemo attractants
or growth factors so this is a quick
step guide to perform a migration or
innovation experiment in response to
chemo attractants so just to give a
difference between migration and
Innovation so when we say migration so
the cells tend to migrate just in
response to the chemot reactants whereas
in invasion they have to
um
physically cross an ECM barrier in the
culture plate thereby they invade and
pass through the other side of the plate
that's why we call them as invasion so
looking into the steps first we need to
select the right type of insert and pore
size
and then the hanging height of the plate
should be adjusted according to our
media requirement
second the we have to feed the lower
well with media containing the chemo
attract and our growth factor of our
choice then we have to see the cell
suspension on top of the insert
then we have to incubate the cells as do
we are regularly incubate our monolayer
culture
so what happens inside the insert after
incubation
so due to the presence of the chemo
tractin the cells try to tries to cross
the insert barrier by migrating from top
of the insert to the bottom of the
insert as seen in this graphical
representation
so this is an example of breast cancer
cells migration in response to growth
serum at the bottom of the plate so
simply we have cultured mcf7 our mdmb
231 cells on the top of the insert and
serum containing media were placed at
the bottom well
and cells were actively migrated from
top to bottom and the migrated cells are
stained with Crystal Violet and the data
has been depicted here
so as you can see here
the migrated cells are stained in blue
in the wells which contains the serum
and the wells without serum did not help
in migration
so next we have demonstrate an another
application in which the migration of
tumor associated micropages in presence
of colorectal cancer cells has been
demonstrated
so we have cultured the tumor Associated
macrophages on top of the insect and
colorectal cancer cells at the bottom
thereby we asset different applications
such as their undo link capability and
Innovation capacity and then one of the
important cancer homework that is the
epithelial to methane mesenchymal
transition which is called as EMT
induction
foreign
to first to generate the tumor
Associated macrophages so we have used
the human leukemia monocytes called thp1
cells which are treated with PMA upon
they differentiate into a tumor
Associated macrophages as seen in the
images so morphologically you can
identify the difference by looking at
them from from monocytes to macrophages
so this tumor Associated macrophages are
seated on the inserts and the colorectal
cancer cells are seated at the bottom
well so after they reach certain
confluency so we made a scratch to
create a wound and the influence of
tumor Associated macrophages in the
wound healing has been acid here so what
you see here is the assay performed on
HCT 116 cell line so which is a
colorectal cancer cell line seated at
the bottom of the well and then tumor
Associated macrophages
um seeded on top so the results uh shown
to help in the the result show here the
tumor Associated macrophages shown to
help in complete the wound closure
whereas when there is no presence of
tumor Associated macrophages uh the the
wound is not healed
the same experiment has been done with
an another colorectal cancer cell line
which is which is called which is called
hd29 cells uh the similar results has
been observed in wound healing as you
see in presence of tumor Associated
macrophages there is a complete closure
of uh wound in the hd29 cells
so next to assess their Innovation
capacity so what we have done so we have
created an ECM barrier by coating the
inserts within gel tricks and then we
see that colorectal cancer cells on top
of the insect and tumor Associated
macrophages at the bottom
thereby the colon cancer cells could
able to invade the ECM barrier at the
insert and they can migrate to the
bottom of the cell culture insects upon
migration so these cells has been
stained with Crystal Violet and the
results what you see here shows the
difference in the cell population when
they were cultured together
so as I mentioned the epithelial to
mesenchymal transition is an important
marker in understanding the migratory
and invasive properties of cancer cell
hence we assess the gene expression
changes once we culture these tumor
Associated macrophages together with
colorectal cancer cells which shown to
demonstrate key changes in some some
genes when the colon cancer cells are
cultured together with macrophages
okay so next important application we
have demonstrated with cell culture
inserts is modeling the endothelial cell
migration and uh in vitro tumor induced
angiogenesis
so at first what you see here to model
the endothelial cell migration so we
have used qxls seated at the top of the
insert and in the bottom well we have
seated
a well-known angiogen and angiogenic
factors such as pfgf and vegf containing
media and when these conditions are
established Hue excels in response to
bfgf and vegf they are actively migrated
from top of the inserts to the bottom of
the insert
so after migrations these cells are
stained with Crystal Violet and as you
can see in the result there is a strong
migration of uxl's seen in presence of
these growth factors compared to their
control
so next to create a tumor angiogenesis
model in which we can
establish an culture with two different
cell types so basically the tumor cells
influence of endothelial cells to form
tubers can be modeled with this cell
culture inserts for that what we have
done is we have used an ovarian cancer
cell type which is called Skov over
three
they are proven to release vgf in their
micro environment and this vagf is
recognized by QX cells to Form
endothelial Tubes
so uh so as a quick step guide so the
steps to model this in a Cell culture
answer system first you have to select
the right type of inset and we have to
coat the bottom well with geltrex ECM
layer because the uxls require the ECM
coating to Form endothelial Tubes
followed by the Hue excels will be
seated on top of the coating and the
next step would be we can see the cancer
cells on top of the inset so now we have
established an uh dual cell culture dual
cell type culture system where you have
a cancer cell on top of the insert and
you have in qxls in the bottom well
so upon incubation what happens as you
can see on the right hand side image so
inside the inside the these cancer cells
which are sq3 cells tend to migrate to
the bottom of the insert and then it
secretes vgf uh in the bottom well that
enables the ux cells to respond to Form
endothelial Tubes
so these are the results of the tumor
engine angiogenesis model we have
established in the insert system as you
can see it has developed a beautiful end
of the little tubes the far left image
shows in the absence of cancer cells Hue
excels fail to Form Tubes whereas in the
presence of sq3 cells they actively Form
Tubes because of the growth factor vgf
released by the cancer cells which
happened due to the paracrine signaling
after migrated cancer cells at the
bottom of the insects
so one advantage of use using this cell
culture inserts while Imaging with
fluorescent dyes since these two
different cell types are in two
different layers you can stain them with
two dice and you can image them in a
single plate only
so as you can see here the green dye
here represented represents the Hue XLS
and the red dye represents the cancer
cells at the insert
so the last Model I would like to
demonstrate is a triple core culture
system that is modeling three different
cell types using the cell culture insert
system
so here we try to model the bone
metastasis in vitro using the cell
culture insects typically in a bone
metastasis condition it involves three
different type of cells the first one is
the tumor cells second is endothelial
cells third are the bone cells
so the tumor cells actually invade the
ECM barrier at the tissues and interacts
them with the endothelial cells which
leads to the trans endothelial migration
of these cells thereby meta States the
osteos osteocytes at the bone
so we try to mimic this system using our
cell culture inserts
so to perform this experiment in the
insert system first we culture the
osteocytes at the bottom belt
and then second we cultured the
endothelial cells at the bottom side of
the insert so this is a tricky step
where first we need to coat the surface
of the insert with an ECM such as gel
tricks and then the insert is kept in an
upside bottom position to seat the
endothelial cells and an overnight
incubation helps uh helps in othering
these endothelial cells to the insert
which are grown until they become
tightly confident to create a physical
barrier
so at last we see the tumor cells on top
of the insect thereby achieving a triple
co-culture system
and all these three different type of
cells can be stained with different
fluorescence dyes and they can be
individually imaged under a fluorescence
microscope
foreign
so these are the results of the triple
Co culture experiment we have done
so we can see the transcendothelial
migration in presence of tumor cells and
endothelial cells and osteocytes whereas
in the absence of endothelial cells
there is no transcendothelial migration
is seen so the difference here is
captured by staining both the cells in
two different fluorescence dyes the red
depicts the endothelial sense and the
blue depicts the osteocytes
okay so beyond the cancer biology
applications these non-sell culture
insert systems can be used for a variety
of applications such as
transport studies
mainly to name drug transport across
epithelial and endothelial barriers and
to study drug transport across brain
microascular endothelial cells such as
we can even create a blood-brain a Blood
Primary barrier model using the cell
culture inserts
and then it can be also used for tissue
engineering like angiogenesis we can use
them to model different epidermal and
epithelial tissue models which help in
skin tissue modeling
and then we can do other regular
co-cultivation studies to study any two
different type of cell to cell
interaction and also we can study cell
substrate interaction with this cell
culture inserts
so to more to know more about the
detailed Protocols of the applications
described here you can visit our cell
culture inserts page either by scanning
the code on the right hand side or you
can simply visit
thermofisher.com cell culture inserts
also we haven't dedicated cell culture
learning and Resource Center where you
will get better guidance on choosing the
right cell type media and reagent style
it to the cell culture inserts
well that's all I had for this webinar
thank you everyone for your kind
attention and I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you Reyes for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
now let's get started
our first question here what factors
should be considered When selecting the
appropriate cell culture insert for a
specific experiment
okay thank you for the question so
typically when you design an experiment
uh you will be choosing a particular
type of cells so that will be your first
Factor so it depends on what type of
cell you use you can choose the kind of
dish you want to use so generally these
non-sell culture insert system comes
with different formats such as it comes
in 24 well format 6 well format also in
trial performers so depends on the the
size you require for your experiment you
can you have to choose first the uh the
format of your plate and then the most
important thing will be the pore size of
the cell culture inserts because the
pore size
varies depends on the type of assay you
do for example if you are doing an uh
transport transport studies such as you
know studying chemore tract in essay
from top to bottom that will require a
smaller pore size for example 0.4
micrometer but if you are doing
migration and Innovation like studies
and it depends on the size of your cell
you have to choose your pore size
suppose if your cells are very big you
can go up to eight micrometer pore size
so it it varies according to your type
of experiment you perform so the second
most important thing will be choosing
your pore size and third will be once
you initiate your experiment
um so you need to choose how much of
volume of media you're going to use in
the culture insert so depends on that as
you seen in the slides you can choose
different heights in the self-ager
inserts so you have low medium and then
highest portion so if you're keeping it
for longer days you can use use the
highest pushing and then if you're using
uh for you know couple of days you can
go for the lowest one so these are the
general factors to consider before you
choose circle chair inserts
okay thank you
um another question here do cell culture
inserts affect the growth and behavior
of cells compared to monolayer
technically no it won't affect the
growth and behavior of the cell the
reason is because these cell culture
inserts are also made up of the poly
coordinate material which is the one we
regularly use for the tissue culture
treated flasks so both are manufactured
with the same material so it will enable
the attachment growth just like in your
regular flasks so it won't change or
affect the growth and behavior of your
cells
thank you our next question can cell
culture inserts alone be used with
different types of cell culture vessels
um So currently there is no Universal
Design of cell culture inserts available
so brand to Grant company to company the
self-conciliences differ
so what you've seen here is Nung cell
culture inserts so they are compatible
with Nung cell culture carrier plates
so if you order that career Plate System
so if you technically see there will be
a multiple plate and then there will be
a carrier plate on top of it there will
be an insert so that they are
specifically manufactured to fit in that
career plate so you can't actually use
the cell culture inserts with some other
brand or some other type
uh but one tip would be so all these
three components can be ordered
separately suppose if you have a
multiple plate and carrier plate already
you can retain them and just you can
order the cell culture inserts alone or
if you have cell culture inserts you can
order the carrier plates alone so you
don't need to order all three uh always
whenever you start an experiment so that
will that will save you some cost
uh but otherwise they are compatible to
the respective design vessels
thank you
um another question here is how do we
image cells with different hanging
Heights in cell culture inserts and will
it affect the focus and resolution
yeah that's a good question so that
that's an important question as well
because while you image at different
heights definitely it will affect your
focus and resolution so for that purpose
what we recommend is so suppose if you
are using a highest portion in your cell
culture inserts so before you image
actually you have to bring it down to
the lowest position so in order to
reduce the space between the bottom of
the plate and your insert and the lowest
position
the gap between the lowest portion is
less than one millimeter so when you
keep your inserts at the lowest portion
technically it will not cause any Focus
or a solution problem and we have tried
with multiple experiments it did not
give any issues but if you keep them at
you know in a medium position or highest
position definitely it will not focus it
since the distance between the bottom
and the cell culture insert is more so
in that case we always recommend bring
down your inserts to a lowest pushing
and then you can image that will solve
the problem
thank you some great questions just a
reminder if you have any more please go
ahead and enter them and to ask a
question box
another question we have here is how do
we detach cells from cell culture
inserts and is there any different
protocol used
no we don't use any different protocol
it's just like how you do in in your
regular multiple plates so you can use
the comment dissociation reagents like
trypsin or EDTA to detach them as I
mentioned these are made up of poly
coordinate and then we don't alter any
protocol in that dissociation so right
away you can just add them and then they
will detach after few minutes and then
you can go ahead and do as you do in
your regular cell culture so we we did
not prescribe any specific protocol for
this so you can stick to the one what
you have already doing in your lab
thank you for that
um another question can we reuse the
cell culture inserts after an experiment
uh no they are not designed for
multi-use
um so these are made up made for single
use experiments so generally any plastic
when you try to reuse that can seriously
contaminate your culture so and it is
not autoclavable so these are all made
for single use so you can use one time
and then you have to use fresh one when
you perform an experiment next so these
are not recommended to use multiple
times so it will definitely affect your
the upcoming experiments you do
thank you
um next question can cell culture
inserts be used for 3D cell culture
experiments
yeah that's a good one uh but right now
we haven't explored anything on 3D cell
culture experiments the reason is as you
know 3D cell culture experiments
typically tend to suspend yourselves in
the form of spirits and organoids so
these uh these cell culture inserts are
actually
self-culture treated just like your
regular flasks or multiple plates so if
you see them you know like it will go
and just attach to the bottom so it will
not give that suspended culture
so we haven't really experimented
anything 3D three device in this circle
here inserts
um but if you want to try I can
recommend like maybe your bottom
multiple plate can be a ultra low
attachment plate so you can just swap
the regular multiple plate instead of
that you can use a ultra low attachment
plate that may help to suspend your 3D
samples only at the bottom but
definitely uh you can't you know suspend
them in the cell culture insects uh
since you know they tend to attach to
the membrane currently we don't have
have any protocols or recommendation to
use this cell culture inserts for 3D
cell culture
great thank you for that insight and
thank you so much Reyes do you have any
final comments for our audience
yeah if you if you have any more
questions or like queries regarding
um the cell culture inserts or if you
don't know you know how to use them for
a particular experiment so we have more
protocols and detailed uh you know
recommendations available in our website
as I shown in the URL so you can go to
that and then you can refer our
documentations and or you can reach to
our customer support team they will help
you us to you know like how to use these
cell culture inserts for your experiment
thank you again Reyes for your time
today and your important research we'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational
webcasts
but before we go
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitting during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you everyone